je vous emmène donc dans l'espace mais
alors pour parler business la lune les
stations spatiales le tourisme en
apesanteur ou pourquoi pas dans
plusieurs décennies l'exploitation des
richesses minières d'un astéroïde c'est
à une privatisation de l'espace que l'on
est en train d'assister avec Adama
manœuvre des milliardaires célèbres
Norbert évangéliste
il me tarde en mars dernier Blue Origin
la société spatiale de Jeff Bezos PDG
d'Amazon
réussissait son quatrième volet habité
en moins d'un an
face à lui Elon Musk tire bien mieux son
épingle du jeu le patron du constructeur
automobile Tesla multiplie les vols vers
la stratosphère depuis la création de
SpaceX en 2002
mais os et muse ont en commun d'avoir
développé une technologie permettant de
réutiliser les fusées une première mais
la société spatiale d'Elon musk a
enchaîné jusqu'à 51 lancements l'année
dernière une véritable performance
imaginez sur 365 jours c'est en gros un
lancement tous les six jours entre 6 et
7 jours et hop on relance c'est quelque
chose qui est inédit totalement inédit
ça n'est jamais arrivé il faut savoir
que certaines semaines il avait SpaceX
avait trois lancements dans la semaine
sur moins de 7 jours c'est-à-dire qu'il
y avait un lancement en Floride 24
heures après vous aviez un lancement
depuis la base de Californie et 48
heures après un lancement depuis la base
de Floride c'est lancement à répétition
sont toute la stratégie économique du
nouveau patron de Twitter qui ne perd
pas le nord pour le temps après avoir
dépensé des milliards dans sa conquête
de l'espace Elon Musk rentabilise son
argent en expédiant notamment pour la
prestigieuse NASA des sondes vers la
Station spatiale internationale
[Applaudissements]
plutôt que de créer des secteurs
supplémentaires on va faire le travail
aux autres et on va dire voilà combien
ça nous coûterait si on demandait à
quelqu'un de nous envoyer des
astronautes vers la Station spatiale
internationale donc on est capable de
mettre tel enveloppe et ben on va
demander à des gens qui veut faire ça
qui va faire le taxi vers la Station
spatiale internationale prochaine
objectif du multimilliardaire permettre
l'accès à Internet par tout sur la
planète en propulsant en plus des 3000
qu'il possède déjà quelques 40 000
nouveaux satellites
[Musique]
d'acteurs privés au sens entreprises qui
vont soit de manière plus autonome
qu'autrefois développer des outils faire
du business en utilisant malgré tout de
l'argent public venu de la NASA ou des
armées ou de leur en Europe des agences
spatiales en général et puis il y a
aussi tout un nouveau business de de
société purement privée qui vont essayer
de faire de l'argent du business donc là
pour le coup de manière autonome sans
soutien public et puis enfin il se
trouve que un certain nombre de ces
entrepreneurs ont un rêve qui est un
petit peu pas que financier qui dépasse
un peu ça ce qui fait que ça met une
ambiance de de volonté alors le plus
connu c'est Elon Musk mais c'est pas le
seul de vouloir faire quelque chose de
privé d'explorer les planètes sans
aucune rentabilité
et donc c'est la combinaison de ces
trois éléments qui font qu'il y a cette
impression de privatisation avec une
dimension qui est vraiment intéressante
Christelle Aston Lépine vous nous
expliquerez tout à l'heure ce que vous
développez avec votre programme blast ça
en prendra le temps de le faire mais
déjà si on va pas dresser toute la liste
mais il y a beaucoup de startups de
petites entreprises qui qui sont déjà
actives dans ce domaine de la conquête
spatiale ce qu'on imagine pas quoi moi
je suis né je suis passionné d'espace je
suis né à l'air des des monstres qui
était la NASA côté russe c'était Soyouz
en France ça s'appelait l'aérospatiale à
l'époque en vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est donc là on a des petites
entreprises qui sont déjà présentes vous
avez tout à fait raison en fait il y
avait 25 ans si vous vouliez travailler
dans le spatial vous aviez pas le choix
fallait rentrer effectivement à
l'Aérospatiale au CNES et puis bon voilà
la carrière était plutôt tout tracé et
aujourd'hui ce qui est extraordinaire et
bon j'irai en France c'est très vrai
depuis cinq six ans on a des des jeunes
ou moins jeunes d'ailleurs un des
entrepreneurs en tous les cas des jeunes
entrepreneurs qui décident parce que ils
ne trouvent pas leur compte dans les
programmes actuels effectivement public
il trouve que ça ne va pas répondre
finalement ni aux besoins de la France
parce que ce sont des gens qui ont quand
même envie de d'apporter aussi des
solutions pour pour la France pour
l'Europe ni effectivement qui vont
répondre à leurs rêves et donc ils vont
créer ils vont créer leur start-up de
donc ils vont fabriquer des lanceurs il
y a deux exemples en tête absolument
donc ne serait-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a on
a 8 startups en France qui veulent
fabriquer des micro lanceurs et donc
tous avec
des mini fusées
et donc tous avec quelque part un
business model différent donc on va voir
celle qui va être la mini fusée pour le
mini satellite même le Nano lanceur pour
le Nano satellite donc satellite
à chaussures c'est une voiture 70 kg
donc oui ça reste non ça reste une
charge utile quand même qui peut
effectivement apporter des services donc
et donc ça c'est c'est un c'est une
vision un peu différente et intéressante
parce que du coup on va apporter à cette
charge utile le même service que pour le
faire Arianespace pour les grosses pour
les gros satellites donc en s'assurant
qu'effectivement ça va bien ça va bien
se passer tout au long on va dire de la
vie du satellite jusqu'à son jusqu'à son
envoi en orbite et ensuite on a d'autres
solutions donc qui sont avec des
nouvelles technologies de la propulsion
hybride de la propulsion effectivement
locks méthane donc chacun en fait
s'empare du sujet un petit peu à sa
manière que ce soit au niveau de la
techno au niveau de l'entreprise alors
on donnera évidemment beaucoup d'autres
exemples mais c'est déjà étonnant je
trouve enfin j'imagine que vous êtes
peut-être dans le même état que moi de
se dire qu'il y a des entreprises comme
français qui sont qui se mettent en
capacité de construire un lanceur une
fusée pour envoyer des satellites dans
l'espace on pensait que c'était réservé
aux énormes agences spatiales ou aux
milliardaires
américains ou anglo-saxons il y a une
expression qu'on va employer peut-être
plusieurs fois dans ce débat c'est
l'expression new space alors c'est quoi
le nouvel espace de quoi on parle quand
on dit newspace c'est excellente
question alors j'ai même pas réfléchi à
cette question j'aurais dû mais il me
semble que c'est en lien quand même
est-ce qu'on a dit précédemment c'est à
dire cette notion tout d'un coup de
d'avoir une perspective de gagner de
l'argent même au niveau d'une start-up
pour travailler dans le spatial ça peut
être directement faire un produit comme
une fusée comme on vient d'évoquer mais
ça peut être très souvent des startups
qui vont être elles-mêmes qui vont avoir
pour clients des grosses compagnies qui
continuent à être très active mais en
réalité une autre manière de voir les
choses c'est de dire que le newspace
vient du fait que alors que à une époque
chaque satellite était un espèce de
chef-d'oeuvre prototype qui était fait
avec soin ou alors avec un savoir-faire
énorme et très compliqué venu des
grandes des grandes compagnies il y a
une notion maintenant de miniaturisation
de on va dire de systématisation
de il y a un petit côté c'est des choses
qui sont standards on peut faire à la
limite des petits satellites à la chaîne
puis on va mettre des instruments
différents ce qui fait que tout d'un
coup on peut faire un produit spatial
sans le mythe qui est associé à
Apollo ou je ne sais quoi pour pas trop
cher et ça ça libère beaucoup de choses
qui fait que maintenant effectivement
quand on regarde les satellites qui sont
lancés dans l'espace actuellement de nos
jours il y a quand même une grande
quantité vous ne soupçonnez pas grande
quantité de petits nano comme on disait
mini ça te fait micro satellite donc de
quelques dizaines de kilos quelques
centaines de kilos mais il y en a
vraiment beaucoup c'est des on appelle
ça une constellation de satellites c'est
ça il y a parfois des constellations et
d'ailleurs ça on peut les voir passer si
enfin pas tous mais de temps en temps
c'est ce que l'on voit parfois c'est
après un lancement alors les plus connus
c'est les lancements de spaces qui sont
vraiment nombreux on a pensé tout à
l'heure dans dans le dans le petit
documentaire là que que
SpaceX envoie lance à lancer presque 50
fusées l'année dernière il y en a une
bonne fraction qui sont pour lancer 50
microsatellites à la fois qui vont
servir effectivement à faire ce réseau
de satellites Starling pour amener
internet un peu partout d'accord et donc
juste après un lancement d'une telle
mission vous avez des grappes de
satellites que peut-être certains ont
déjà vu qui passent dans l'espace mais
il y a pas que on peut voir aussi des
grappes de satellites oneweb il y en a
un peu moins maintenant il y en a eu
donc vous voyez 15 20 jusqu'à 50
satellites qui passent quand même un
petit collier dans le ciel alors il y a
une page importante de de dans la
conquête spatiale qui s'est tourné quand
une fusée une capsule spécifique
justement à transporter les astronautes
de la NASA je vous propose d'écouter le
patron de l'agence américaine donc on
est le 2 août 2020 après le retour sain
et sauf de ces hommes
quelle journée incroyable nous avons
écrit une page d'histoire nous entrons
dans une nouvelle ère en matière de vol
spatial humain la NASA n'est plus
l'acheteur le propriétaire et
l'exploitant de tout le matériel
nous allons devenir un client Un client
parmi d'autres sur un marché commercial
très solide pour les vols habités en
orbite basse
je voudrais que on évoque ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que la NASA devient un
client des entreprises privées enfin
c'est là aussi c'est un espèce de
changement de modèle est-ce que ça veut
vraiment dire ça alors qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que effectivement
la NASA plutôt que de passer commande
directement à un industriel qu'elle a
choisi parce que elle a fait une
spécification détaillée et que
l'industriel a répondu au mieux sur la
spécification de la NASA là elle va
choisir un industriel qui a choisi en
fait sont son produit voilà c'est pas
elle qui a fait la spécification
détaillée du produit je crois que la
grosse différence elle est là après bien
comprendre pardon de vous interrompre
c'est à dire que le cahier des charges
c'est l'industriel qui en fait c'est ce
qui s'est passé
avec Elon Musk au début il a créé sa
fusée il en a mis trois au tapis et la
quatrième il a réussi et à partir de là
il a dit bah voilà je peux vendre des
choses et la NASA a dit bah OK je vais
effectivement vous vous faire vous
commander du coup des lanceurs sur
lesquels vous pourrez lancer des
satellites et pardon à chaque fois
j'essaye d'être le plus pédago possible
c'est la fusée qui revient sur terre
c'est celle-là
exactement et donc en fait on a
effectivement un petit changement de
paradismes ou c'est l'acteur public qui
choisit qui fait sa roadmap ben
d'observation enfin de d'observation
spatiale que ce soit sur les lanceurs
les satellites aller sur la lune et qui
va laisser du coup finalement une grosse
partie du choix du résultat au à
l'acteur privé et en l'occurrence c'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire que
c'est Elon Musk qui a choisi de faire sa
fusée aujourd'hui donc la Falcon 9 comme
il l'a fait c'est et du coup par contre
la NASA lui a commandé effectivement des
lancements donc c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle
on dit que c'est un acteur privé mais ça
reste effectivement une commande
publique de l'argent public avec de
l'argent public on a bien compris et
est-ce que ça veut là on parle quand
même d'une forme de recomposition un peu
un peu économique est-ce que ça veut ça
a pas mis fin à la concurrence entre les
États pour autant non au contraire je
dirais ouais quelque part ce que cela
fait le grand changement c'est que je
vais reformuler un petit peu mais en
parlant en particulier du cas des
capsules parce que ça c'est presque plus
parlant des vaisseaux spatiaux donc pour
la capsule Apollo pour on va dire la
navette spatiale la NASA avait vraiment
conçu totalement le système il y avait
dit je cherche un industriel pour faire
le booster à poudre pour faire la
capsule pour l'équipage etc avec les
plans déjà prêt là
et c'est pour les nouvelles capsules
comme par exemple la capsule de Lon musk
donc SpaceX qui s'appelle could dragon
le NASA a dit j'ai besoin d'un système
qui m'amène des astronautes dans orbite
basse pour faire différentes choses
alors SpaceX a conçu une capsule soit
dit en mauvais façon il était en même
temps il y a eu un autre marché qui est
passé auprès de Boeing qui devait faire
la même chose et puis une mise en
concurrence quand il y a une mise en
concurrence et en fait c'était c'était
même un plus plus précis que ça il y a
eu un appel d'offres et chaque
industriel a pu répondre en disant moi
je vais le faire et je vais avoir besoin
de tant d'argent spécifique ça demande
est presque deux fois moins d'argent que
Boeing c'est déjà un bon argument tout
fonctionne depuis des années et Boeing
et bah toujours pas réussi à envoyer des
astronautes parce qu'à chaque fois il y
a un problème donc voyez c'est très
frappant le succès de SpaceX de par
exemple quand tu regardes ce point de
détail là mais je reviens sur mon
histoire
et donc maintenant Space X l'autre
différence c'est SpaceX possède son
système donc il peut parfaitement vendre
la capsule le vol spatial a des
touristes voire à d'autres des états
donc il y a des efforts
lui interdit pas de vendre je sais pas
l'Agence spatiale européenne ou Horus
quoi pas du tout pas du tout au
contraire chinois
je pense qu'il doit avoir un petit
cahier
d'accord c'est déjà prévu mais
effectivement par exemple il est il est
bien clair que donc il y a cette capsule
est maintenant offerte à des astronautes
on va dire commerciaux c'est-à-dire
qu'ils vont payer leur vol ça va être
des milliardaires ça va être parfois des
scientifiques ou des sociétés privées
mais ça peut aussi être des États qui
vont dire ah bah j'aimerais bien mettre
mon premier astronaute dans l'espace et
puis comme j'ai pas de collaboration je
vais juste payer SpaceX et puis ça ça a
déjà eu lieu quasiment donc maintenant
revenons en arrière sur la compétition
entre État en fait
pour ce je peux soit à quoi vous pensez
c'est peut-être à la guerre froide les
années 60 quand vraiment le l'espace
signifie du prestige le soft power etc
et bien c'est toujours un peu présent et
pourquoi parce que c'est pas tellement
entre l'Europe et les États-Unis
évidemment mais c'est plutôt avec la
Chine et là comme vous l'avez évoqué il
y a une rivalité réelle qui est moins
nette que pendant la guerre froide mais
qui est quand même réel et puis il reste
aussi les Russes et vous savez bien que
c'est assez tendu donc finalement dans
l'espace on retrouve ces rivalités là
c'est moins clair pour bien sûr d'autres
pays comme l'Europe le Japon etc pour ce
qui concerne les hommes dans l'espace
alors puisqu'on parle de de concurrence
avec les États et mise à Bastille on va
s'intérêt s'intéresser un peu à Emmanuel
Macron à sa voilà ce que comment il
essaye de de promouvoir la France
spatiale en quelque sorte
alors lui propulser des startups
françaises sur des grands projets de
conquêtes de l'espace c'était un depuis
le début de son pouvoir en 2017 c'était
le rêve non secret d'Emmanuel Macron et
on en attendait pas moins de celui qui
se présentait alors comme le président
de la start-up nation vous vous souvenez
de départ c'était de dire la France a
toujours été à l'origine d'innovation
dans le domaine du spatial il n'y a pas
de raison que cela change et même si
Elon Musk ou Jeff Bezos se partagent
pour l'instant le gâteau newspace dont
on parlait la France peut se refaire une
place majeure ça le promoteur de la
start-up nation en est convaincu mais il
comprend vite que le temps et puis aussi
l'argent sûrement est compté face au
projet des milliardaires boostés par les
agences américaines on parlait de la
NASA à l'instant le seul moyen crédible
c'est de jouer la carte européenne il
alerte les ministres européens de
l'espace qui étaient réunis à Toulouse
ça c'était le 16 février 2022 on
l'écoute
parce que si notre industrie est
aujourd'hui attaquée
disputé par de nouveaux acteurs qui ne
sont plus sur le sol européen
s'il nous restions en quelque sorte
inertes nous sortirions de l'histoire
mais le choix que nous sommes en train
de faire collectivement est à l'inverse
agir en urgence
c'est pour ne pas nous faire imposer des
solutions par d'autres une vision
européenne de la conquête spatiale oui
le jeune président a compris une chose
enfin le jeune président à l'époque il
est toujours
c'est par les entreprises privées aidé
par le secteur public que les
innovations majeures vont naître et que
les projets les plus fous peuvent se
réaliser les premiers pas réussi de la
fusée muquienne Starship vous en parliez
tout à l'heure Christelle c'est en
témoigne en fait donc là si j'ai bien
compris c'est un lanceur spatial super
lourd la Starship et qui a réussi au
bout de quelques essais sans maîtrise de
l'espace pas de souveraineté
technologique industrielle économique
stratégique ou militaire c'est ce que
dit Emmanuel Macron mais la force de
l'entrepreneur devenue président de fois
ne suffit pas il est obligé de revoir à
la baisse ces ambitions qui sont
peut-être un peu trop grandes pour les
petits appétits européens pourquoi ce
serait impossible d'aller plus loin en
Europe mais déjà difficile de rattraper
le retard parce qu'on en a pris du
retard la future fusée Ariane 6 trois
ans de retard le lanceur italien vegaset
a raté son premier lancement l'Europe
n'a plus de lanceur disponible à court
terme en tout cas la guerre en Ukraine
qui a mis fin à la collaboration avec
les Russes dans ce domaine et peut-être
les arguments du président ont quand
même favorisé la montée en puissance du
budget européen ça a augmenté récemment
et Macron a aussi obtenu quelque chose
d'important c'est l'accord sur un
principe de préférence européenne pour
les lancements d'y institutionnels
c'est-à-dire qu'on va choisir des
lanceurs européens et pas forcément
prendre ceux des autres pays et en plus
le lanceur européen ils sont financés
ils sont subventionnés par le public
mais pas de décision en tout cas quand
un investissement majeur pour développer
par exemple un programme européen de vol
habité ce qui pourrait jouer parce que
c'est un des grands enjeux l'Europe a
seulement décidé de publier d'ici mars
2023 un rapport sur le sujet donc c'est
pas encore gagné et puis il y a les
concurrences internes qui n'arrangent
rien l'Allemagne qui veut un petit peu
jouer de son côté résultat nos
astronautes même le grand Thomas Pesquet
doivent embarquer parfois sur des
navettes américaines d'ailleurs lors de
sa visite aux États-Unis en novembre
2022 le président Emmanuel Macron s'est
transformé en VRP de la France et de
l'Europe ta chambre renforcer la
coopération spatiale avec les États-Unis
mais il est même devenu l'agent du
célèbre astronaute français Thomas
Pesquet provoquant un fou rire de la
vice-présidente américaine Kamala Harris
alors on va on va peut-être profiter de
cette analyse de d'Émilie
Christelle Lépine pour détailler un peu
ce que vous faites avec ce programme
d'accélération parce que ça ça va un peu
dans cette logique là qui consiste à
quoi à faire émerger à faire grandir des
des startups françaises ou européennes
voilà c'est exactement ça en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que quand vous avez un
ingénieur souvent ou un chercheur qui a
une très belle idée qui est liée à la
science il va avoir besoin effectivement
d'investissement donc nous on va l'aider
à trouver des investisseurs privés il va
avoir besoin moins de clients donc on va
l'aider à le mettre en contact en fait
avec des Grands Comptes un des grands
groupes comme safrante Alès etc pour
effectivement avec lui créer ce qu'on
appelle des profs concept c'est-à-dire
tester en fait donc l'époque tester son
idée quoi et donc effectivement ça peut
être ça peut être de déconstration si on
a des gens qui font des constellations
ça peut être des des parties de lanceur
des drones voilà tout ce qu'il faut pour
effectivement qu'on reste très bon en
France dans dans ces sujets là et ils
vont également avoir besoin de quelque
chose que nous on fait particulièrement
dans le programme blast c'est-à-dire
qu'on les apprennent juste à devenir
entrepreneur donc pendant trois mois on
fait des bouts de camp ou on leur
apprend rapidement parce que trois mois
ça va quand même très vite tout ce qu'il
faut savoir pour devenir entrepreneur ça
va bien évidemment du marketing de la
communication au business plan au
business model au RH et une fois qu'on a
fait ça pendant trois mois qu'ils ont
rencontré tous les investisseurs de la
place de Paris les grands comptes parce
que tous les sièges sociaux sont aussi
sur Paris les grands comptes c'est quoi
les grandes entreprises les grandes
entreprises du domaine aéronautique
spatial défense
et donc effectivement on en a une petite
dizaine on va dire dont les sièges
sociaux sont à Paris et avec lesquels
nous starburst on a des liens
particuliers des liens privilégiés parce
qu'on est également cabinet de conseils
donc d'un côté on va conseiller en fait
ces grands groupes pour leur stratégie
de développement de l'autre côté on va
conseiller les startups et on fait ce
qui s'appelle de l'open innovation c'est
à dire qu'on va mettre les deux en même
temps on va leur apprendre les
mutuellement à travailler ensemble en
fait parce que les grands groupes ont
besoin effectivement de ces startups
pour amener des briques technologies qui
vont les aider à se distribuer les
startups ont besoin également des grands
groupes donc tout ça se veut quand même
un écosystème bienveillant de manière à
ce que on puisse effectivement être en
capacité comme la dit Monsieur Macron
d'être en compétition par rapport aux
questions tout à l'heure on en parlait
Elon Musk c'est aussi le rêve d'un petit
garçon presque un qui veut qui veut
serrer fous et qui finalement rend tout
possible c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il dit
c'est pas possible mais j'y vais et ça
va être possible qu'est-ce qui nous
manque en France ou en Europe justement
pour avoir cette culture
de la possibilité hors-norme qu'est-ce
qui fait que on peut changer au-delà de
l'argent évidemment mais ce rêve fou qui
devient une réalité parce qu'on sent
qu'il y a ça il y a cet aspect là mais
moi je pense qu'on y est je veux dire
aujourd'hui on a un garçon qui qui n'a
pas 25 ans et voilà qui n'a pas fait des
grandes études pour pour y arriver qui
est devenu entrepreneur qui a fait ses
premiers essais donc d'une d'une mini
fusée qui marche qu'il a fait en Écosse
parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à le faire en
France parce que les moyens d'essai
n'étaient pas prêts alors que ce sont
nos acteurs historiques qui qui
connaissent mais on est un petit peu
comment dire figé aussi malheureusement
dans une après une administration un
petit peu lourde une lourdeur qui fait
qu'on n'a pas le temps de réponse qu'il
faut pour aller et ce voilà il a il a
décidé de trouver l'endroit pour le
faire il a fait ses essais il a réussi
et lui ce qu'il veut bien évidemment
c'est s'emparer de ce de ce domaine là
il commence par un micro lanceur mais
moi je lui souhaite de réussir et il
fera un gros lanceur aujourd'hui comme
Elon Musk j'ai un autre entrepreneur qui
est en train de créer une constellation
comme et comme Elon Musk et là c'est pas
Starling c'est c'est peut-être le petit
frère ou le grand frère je sais pas
parce que l'idée c'est que cette
constellation elle soit plus performante
avec une meilleure latence et des
technologies qui font que ben voilà là
encore ce seront des technologies
françaises c'est à dire que sinon on
veut notre propre constellation demain
on a ces acteurs là et ils veulent se
mettre sur l'ensemble de la chaîne de la
valeur et ça ça c'est important
François Forget on va ils on va se
projeter un peu alors c'est pas du tout
pour tout de suite c'est même pas pour
dans plusieurs décennies mais une une
planète business vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est une planète ou un
astéroïde sur lequel on sur laquelle on
irait faire du business parce que ça
peut être une de perspective pour des
milliardaires qui investissent
aujourd'hui vous me dites pour l'instant
ils investissent mais ils investissent
plus pour le rêve il y a pas de modèle
économique forcément derrière mais
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer si oui à quel
échéance aller sur une planète ou sur un
astéroïde pour le creuser et ramener de
la matière première alors attention j'ai
dit que j'investis pour le rêve il y a
quand même un modèle économique très
solide derrière avec une volonté de
business mais c'est vrai que pour le cas
particulier des lones musk et de haute
Jeff Bezos ou les les sociétés comme
vous pouvez regarder
Rocket laborgs par exemple aux
États-Unis c'est des il y a des gens qui
sont vraiment avec ce rêve là mais ils
ont un bon business plan est-ce que vous
assurer comme tout le monde imagine Elon
Musk gagne de l'argent qu'il réinvestit
dans sa société pour faire des lanceurs
géants pour aller vers son rêve qui
effectivement de d'envoyer des gens sur
Mars etc donc maintenant donc exploiter
une planète
d'exploiter l'espace lointain c'est
quelque chose qui est dans les cartons
on en parle moi je suis un petit peu
sceptique pour les
pas mal d'années à venir pourquoi parce
que en fait par exemple au niveau
scientifique nous nous avons des
collègues ont essayé de ramener des
échantillons de d'astéroïdes pour
l'étudier en laboratoire donc c'est une
complicité assez effarante par exemple
une mission comme Osiris Rex la plus
grosse mission qui a fait ça à ramener
quelques dizaines de grammes on sait pas
encore exactement quelques dizaines de
grammes peut-être un peu sang de 100 g
et ça a été très compliqué ça va bien
tout revenir sur terre et voilà alors
qu'est-ce que on va pas trouver des
diamants dans l'espace on va trouver
allez peut-être qu'on va trouver des
métaux rares de l'or du platine du
palladium que ça coûte combien ça coûte
quelques dizaines d'euros par grammes
alors vous allez me dire si on ramène
trois tonnes ça fait des millions
d'euros mais de la rentabiliser ça pour
aller le chercher malgré tout malgré
tout ça c'est mon sentiment personnel je
suis un peu courte vu et je vois 10 20
ans dans le futur malgré tout il y a des
sociétés privées qui lèvent des fonds et
qui ont pour but vraiment il y a ont
pour but de de développer des moyens
pour aller mining miner donc extraire de
du Mendy minéraux des sur des astéroïdes
proches donc c'est dans les cartons il y
a des bancs qui arrivent à subventionner
cela je suis pas sûr de mettre mon
argent là-dedans alors on va rejoindre
tout de suite un aventurier non pas de
l'espace mais à l'aventurier de d'un
jour de manif à Paris c'est Philippe et
naréjeau merci de finalement voilà
d'avoir essayé de venir et puis d'être
avec nous en duplex je rappelle que vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef de Ciel et
Espace ces questions de privatisation de
l'espace évidemment vous avez beaucoup
travaillé dessus on a évoqué un peu
cette cette nouvelle économique
imbriquée à la fois des milliardaires
les agences historiques ou même des des
startups le business qu'est-ce qui
rapporte aujourd'hui dans l'espace les
télécoms la météo les GPS ça c'est déjà
une un business très rentable c'est ça
oui alors il y a des applications qui
sont majoritairement tournés vers la
terre évidemment qui qui rapporte
puisque il y a
comment dire des données à traiter qui
observent la terre des données à acheter
il y a évidemment tout le business qu'on
imagine sur les communications et les
télécommunications donc ça c'est ça
c'est réel et c'est pas nouveau je
dirais après est-ce qu'il y a un autre
business dans l'espace oui il y a
marginalement le business de certaines
sociétés privées qui font du tourisme
spatial donc qui est réservé à une élite
très argentée à des à des Très Riches
donc c'est c'est pour c'est l'exemple de
des vols suborbitaux qui ont été lancés
par à la fois Virgin galactique avec
l'avion subordonnée
éblou origin avec la capsule new et la
fusée nous sépare donc ça c'est un petit
business mais il concerne
pour aller faire un petit tour dans
l'espace ça coûte ça coûte combien
les tickets c'est je crois que pour j'ai
déjà aux alentours de 200000 € la place
pour un vol subordinale de 15 minutes
donc on voit bien que c'est il y a un
business avec des gens qui ont de
l'argent à dépenser pour ça bon d'accord
et après au-delà si on réfléchit
il faudrait qu'il y ait des richesses à
exploiter dans l'espace et qu'il y ait
un commerce à faire avec l'espace et là
je suis plus circonspect là dessus je
pense qu'il y a le business essentiel
dans l'espace il reste il reste celui de
l'exploration de la politique voire de
la géopolitique qui suppose
investissement massif par les États
malgré tout et que finalement le
business qui peut y avoir pour les
privés sous quelques formes que ce soit
que ce soit sous-traitant ou d'honneur
de services ou offreurs de services en
quelque sorte ben il est il est tourné
vers le public vers l'âge en public
finalement alors je voudrais qu'on ouvre
un chapitre consacré à la lune retour
des missions lunaires et puis peut-être
nous nous en nous enverrons vers mars
après déjà pour eux et évoquer
Christelle à sorghepine le fait que là
aussi il y a des entreprises françaises
qui travaillent alors donc on est dans
dans le business de la lune d'une
certaine façon à quoi à quoi elle
travaille à améliorer le quotidien de
des astronautes quand ils seront là-bas
si on se projette un peu c'est quoi le
parallèlement effectivement aux visions
pour le coup des états donc de
s'installer sur la lune ou de mettre des
vaisseaux qui vont tourner autour de la
Lune donc avec des grands programmes
comme Artémis et ben oui ça va générer
effectivement un business tout autour on
a des startups qui veulent fabriquer des
maisons lunettes qui serviront par
exemple de base de Caen pour les
astronautes s'ils doivent voyager un
petit peu longtemps autour de la Lune on
en a qui pense et ça c'est intéressant
parce que c'est aussi applicable sur
terre ou dans tous les milieux
contraints donc à fabriquer de la
nourriture vraiment dans des milieux
confinés fermés durables en plus
nourriture durable on a aussi
ses patates sur Mars on a tous l'image
en tête et donc c'est en l'occurrence
c'est interstellar qui qui fait ça donc
c'est mené par une jeune femme parce que
je le tiens à le souligner parce que
c'est suffisamment rare notamment dans
notre milieu aéronautique spatial
défense et d'ailleurs également on en a
une dont qui s'appelle the exploration
compagnie où là l'idée c'est de créer un
vaisseau modulaire modulable
réutilisables pour justement faire des
allers-retours entre la France la France
la Terre la Lune et puis les les
stations les stations orbitaires donc
donc ça commence là encore à soulever
des énergies qu'on n'a pas finalement
dans nos programmes publics c'est ça qui
est parce que il y a eu effectivement
alors le point de départ c'est quand
même la décision de retourner sur la
Lune oui donc ces entreprises sinon
elles travailleraient pas dans le vide
c'est vrai qu'elles vont se raccrocher
quand même assez grand programme
nationaux lunaires dans lequel
effectivement l'Europe sera participant
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de volonté
quelque part d'autonomie par rapport par
rapport à ça mais du coup
de la vie effectivement de ces
entrepreneurs ça génère des nouvelles
idées je pense qu'il faut quand même
revenir sur sur ce qu'a abordé François
sur la Chine je pense que là on a quand
même quelque chose qui se trame faut
vraiment pas du tout le sous-jouet ou on
a effectivement les Chinois et les
Russes qui sont en train de s'associer
qui ont des visions de s'installer cette
fois-ci sur la lune de manière plus ou
moins durable avec une vraie
exploitation et là on est parti quand
même pour quelque chose qui pourrait pas
très bien se passer si ça effectivement
c'est intéressant votre avis là-dessus
faut savoir ça veut dire quoi c'est dire
que je vais je vais là encore essayer de
simplifier peut-être un peu trop mais
quoi on plante le drapeau chinois et
cette partie de de la lune est à nous au
hasard vers le pôle il y a eu de la où
il y a de la glace qu'on pourrait
transformer en eau c'est ça on peut pas
tout à fait faire ça les les accords
internationaux
qui ont été signés par tous ces gens-là
ne l'empêche de le faire par contre on
peut si on voulait aller quelque part et
exploiter librement sans posséder
l'endroit le le les éventuels minerais
mais pour la Lune comme pour les
astéroïdes que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
il y a pas de rentabilité immédiate par
contre ce qui est vrai c'est que il y a
une il y a un enjeu géopolitique qui est
qu'on peut résumer ainsi c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que le résume les
organismes américains
qui explique pourquoi il faut rester
dans l'espace et surtout envoyer
des astronautes dans l'espace c'est
qu'en gros si imaginons l'Europe et
surtout les États-Unis arrête d'envoyer
des astronautes la Chine et la Russie
continue tout seul ce seront eux qui
pourront décider des règles à venir
tandis que si on continue à y aller et
bien il y aura une table de négociation
etc donc c'est ça l'enjeu c'est un enjeu
qui est quand même pas encore une fois
c'est pas du business immédiat à très
long terme peut-être mais pour l'instant
sur la Lune il y a quand même pas grand
chose à exploiter
pour qu'il serait ramenable sur terre et
utile pour faire du business alors on
reste dans notre thème un privatisation
de l'espace ou l'espace au contraire
bien comme un humanité on va écouter un
autre extrait de du discours de du
président de la République donc ce
c'était au mois de février dernier
devant les ministres européens chargés
de l'espace
l'espace est un bien commun de
l'humanité qui pour continuer à l'être
doit être sorti des seuls logiques
demain marché et de puissance et être
régulée aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas
Philippe et la Régence votre avis
là-dessus est-ce qu'on peut jusqu'où on
peut réguler finalement l'accès à
l'espace la possession d'une partie
d'une planète là encore je fais un peu
de science-fiction mais volontairement
c'est difficile à dire parce que ça
risque d'être quand même effectivement
les premiers qui arrivent qui vont
définir plus ou moins ce qui va se
passer
c'est une terre nouvelle c'est une
nouvelle frontière mais pour l'instant
je pense que comme le disait François
forgé il y a pas vraiment de richesse à
exploiter et qui serait à ramener sur
terre d'ailleurs ça pose un problème
supposant qui dit mettons des milliers
de tonnes d'or sur la lune et qu'on
veuillent les ramener sur terre comme
comme le faisait les galions espagnols à
l'époque de la découverte de l'Amérique
il y aurait un problème un sérieux
problème technique qui est de ramener
des énormes masses vers la terre on ne
ferait pas rentrer un super tanker
rempli de minerais dans l'atmosphère
terrestre à 39000 km à l'heure on s'est
fait revenir des petits vaisseaux mais
même s'il y avait des richesses ce
serait difficile à exploiter du fait
même de l'Atmos de la terre et de
l'attraction terrestre mais ça c'est une
autre chose donc la question risque de
ne pas trop se poser même si les Chinois
installe une base au sol de sur la lune
près du près du pôle sud et que les
américains
s'installent forcément légèrement
ailleurs ils vont pas se mettre les uns
sur les autres il y a que quelques
endroits qui ont été identifiés ou il
fait soleil on peut avoir des panneaux
solaires
j'ai le sentiment que ça finira par une
espèce de de coexistence pacifique
malgré tout un peu comme ça comme la
guerre froide et la course à la Lune
c'était soldé en 1975 avec finalement la
poignée de main Apollo Soyouz avec un
vol commun et l'espace reste
suffisamment hostile pour que ça soit
encore en milieu ou l'entrée de finisse
finisse par l'emporterons le Émilie
qui est toujours de penser à la
régulation et justement l'espace comment
comment on organise on en avait parlé
pour l'intelligence artificielle moi je
pense que ça retarde quelquefois
l'aspect commercial l'aspect business
mais en tout cas l'Europe se positionne
toujours là-dessus il y a la régulation
et puis il y a aussi une question
importante c'est la question de
l'environnement parce que on voit qu'il
y a des débris on voit qu'il y a des
choses qui se font sans foi ni loi et
l'Europe commence aussi à se pencher sur
la question en se disant est-ce qu'on
doit être respectueux de cet
environnement qu'on est en train de
conquérir ou alors est-ce qu'on s'en
fiche complètement et qu'on laisse tous
les débris s'installer des stations ou
des choses qui seraient sur la lune et
on y prête pas du tout attention
l'Europe est vigilante si elle a pas de
commerce là-dessus elle a des idées sur
une régulation je voudrais qu'on termine
et puis on va boucler puisque le sujet
d'ouverture concernait les les
milliardaires qui sont lancés dans la
dans la conquête spatiale il y a
évidemment Elon Musk partons de Tesla et
de spacie Jeff Bezos avec Amazon eblue
origin on l'a pas cité mais Richard
Branson aussi le Britannique avec Virgin
et Virgin galactique le plus avancé
c'est le musk de loin c'est à dire que
en terme de
il a donc développé cette capsule donc
le Cloud dragon qui permet à des non
seulement à la NASA mais aussi à des
milliardaires d'aller dans l'espace et
c'est une réalité il y a plusieurs
sortes de touristes on a mentionné le
vol subordo mais pour
50 millions de dollars et il y a des
clients par personne il y a des clients
qui font à la fois des vols en capsule
individuel il y en a eu un qui
s'appelait le expulsion 4 et il va alors
bientôt suivez cela une mission que ça
va être Polaris down et qui va envoyer
des astronautes qui vont faire des
sorties dans l'espace absolument de
manière privée donc il y a des
milliardaires qui vont s'offrir une
sortie extravéculaire
on va dire c'est des astronautes
commerciaux il y a aussi des astronautes
qui peuvent se payer un accès sur la
Station spatiale internationale c'est
pas nouveau mais il y en a encore eu
récemment il y en aura bientôt dans
quelques mois et donc il y a même une
société qui s'appelle Axium ça vaut le
coup de la cité qui entre qui développe
tout cela qui est un des clients de Elon
Musk qui développe actuellement une
station spatiale indépendante qui va
être pour dans un premier temps collé
enfin mis à l'avant de la Station
spatiale internationale sur lequel des
touristes très riches pourront aller
regarder la terre et faire des
expériences scientifiques il y a même
Tom Cruise je crois qui c'est positionné
Tom Cruise pourrait être un des futurs
c'est pas clair parce qu'il a toujours
pas officialisée alors que ça fait des
années qu'on en parle mais il peut tout
à fait être un des prochains clients
pour aller sur la Station spatiale
internationale il y a même un
milliardaire japonais qui a déjà été sur
la Station spatiale internationale et
qui a acheté une place avec la nouvelle
fusée alors faut pas confondre la Falcon
9 et le Starship de Elon Musk qui a pour
but et qui a déjà acheté sa place avec
plein d'autres artistes il est très
riche pour aller faire un tour de la
lune sur le Starship dans les années à
venir et je pense que ça aura lieu donc
il y a toute une gamme de touristes
ultra milliardaires mais ils sont
nombreux en fait il y a un vrai marché
au point que donc plusieurs sociétés
développent actuellement des projets de
station spatiale privée
Axium mais par exemple blue original
Jeff Bezos en ce moment et je pense ce
sera une réalité un peu écoeurante parce
que c'est on est un peu choqué des fois
quand des milliardaires utilisent le jet
privé sans tenir compte de leur de leur
empreinte carbone là c'est gigantesque
moi en même temps c'est tellement
au-delà de cette espèce de
va pas être un énorme facteur quelque
chose que beaucoup de je crois de gens
trouvent écœurant et puis d'autres sont
fascinés et c'est difficile à avoir un
avis très net
Bernard Arnault veut pas dépenser ses
milliards pour aller dans l'espace mais
c'est ça rejoint la question de poser
Émilie tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
parce que Elon Musk c'est ultra rapide
quand même il crée il crée spécifique il
y a il y a 20 ans il a fêté les 20 ans
l'an dernier il a créé SpaceX il y a 20
ans il a fait à sa manière c'est-à-dire
effectivement à coup de beaucoup
d'échecs qui mine de rien lui apportait
largement plus de succès
qu'effectivement une méthode beaucoup
plus conventionnelle que parce que Jeff
Bezos par contre a fait son lanceur plus
ou moins
les règles de l'art et donc voilà ça
c'est on voit que finalement il a mis
plus de temps et en tous les cas pour
pour une réussite un peu moindre ce
qu'on peut dire quand même c'est que
effectivement ça peut choquer c'est
quand même bon tout ces médias je sais
pas s'ils sont jetés à la poubelle ou
pas mais moi ce que je vois quand même
c'est toute la techno qu'on peut qu'on
peut tirer derrière et ça c'est
intéressant c'est à dire que mine de
rien c'est grâce aussi à ces nouvelles
technologies qu'on va avancer sur la
terre et on termine là-dessus merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat merci
Philippe et la Régence d'être voilà
d'avoir fini par quand même participer à
l'émission des sensibles à l'effort
merci Émilie à très bientôt sur sur ce
plateau je vous dis à demain évidemment
et puis ne ratez pas la matinale Dorian
Mancini demain matin salut
[Musique]